This episode is made possible by the realistic online game war thunder.
Checking out the game through the link in the description below.
Go through that link and you're not only support this show,
but you also get a free premium tango Aircrafts and three days of premium time
as a bonus.
And let's get into APP.
Actually,
before we get into it,
I just want to say that there are French pronunciations in this one.
Indeed,
the man's name himself shall Dougal.
Uh,
that's,
I believe how you pronounce it in French.
I'm going to go with the accepted English pronunciation of Charles de goal
because it's easier for me unless like to describe it up.
There's also other French pronunciations.
If you don't like it,
deal with it all up.
Just have a go at me in the comments below.
I'm not going to read them.
Charles to go was the sort of man who turned heads at six foot five inches in
height.
He towered over his contemporaries and with his regal bearing and from gays,
he exuded an APP,
a fourth right self confidence throughout his life.
His unswerving love for France,
coupled with his determination to right the wrongs of the past,
turned him into a hero of the resistance movement and one of the fringe
republics.
Truly great statesman.
In today's biographics,
we examine the very full life of Charles to goal.
Yeah.
Charles Andre.
Joseph Murray to goal was born on November the 22nd 1819 he was the third of
five children to Henri and genre to goal.
Henri was a military man who had served in the Franco Prussian war by the time
his second son was born.
He was a teacher at a Catholic school in the French industrial region of Lille.
Shortly after the birth of trials,
the family moved to Paris on Rita got the position as the headmaster of the
Jesuit College of the Immaculate Conception.
Andre was a lover of history and the glory of France.
Nights in the goal home would often be spends with the children gathered around
to listen to their father,
regale them with stories of the country's history and the past of their
ancestors have played in it.
Charles would later recall the stories his father would tell them about their
most famous ancestor Sewell,
Johan to Google,
a knight who fought against the English at the battle of [inaudible],
the glorious history of his nation that Charles was learning at the feet of his
father,
came with a distrust of the country's natural enemy of the British.
Henri would not allow his children to learn the English language.
Charles,
his mother,
jome loved to a country more than a husband's Charlotte's,
which later to say that she had an uncompromising love for his country that was
equal to a rented just piety the defeat of France.
So the bachelor of Sedona in 1870 during the Franco Prussian war was a source of
humiliation for all fringe patriots,
including the goals.
They see that with the desire to avenge the shame that had folded upon their
once mighty nation,
they kept this ambition alive in their children with Henri irregularly taking
them to the cemetery at Liberal Shay and having them read aloud the inscription
to the dead of 1870 the SORTA fronds broken their Valliant hands will once more
be reformed by their descendants.
Even though he wasn't the smartest of the five to gold children.
Charles was then natural leader.
He adds a mischievous dominant attitude and he was always organizing some sort
of practical joke on one of his siblings when he was about six he invented his
own language which involved speaking French backwards.
He forced his brothers and sisters to learn it naturally objectives because his
insistence paid off and they all became fluent at it.
This was an early sign of the determination and persistent force of character
that would come to be a trademark of Charles is an adult
like most French boys.
Charles Love to play soldiers.
Yet when he and his brothers lined up that model armies on the bedroom floor,
he would exhibit a seriousness and intensity than two went way beyond the
childhood game.
He always insisted on portraying the French army and would become cold and
dispassionate to during the war games as he put his total energies into
defeating the enemy.
Charles attended the Jesuit College.
His father was the head Masdar.
He was a keen students who love to read and developed an early interest in
philosophy.
By the age of 10 though he had decided that he was going to pursue a life in the
military.
From that point onward,
Charles was single minded in his military focus at the age of 15 he wrote an
essay in which he projected himself forward to the year 1930 whereas general,
the goal,
he led the French army in defeating the Germans.
Finally inflicting vengeance for the defeat of 1870 Charles was determined to
win a place at the military academy.
Saul Sia has hard work at school.
It paid off and it was accepted into the academy in 1909 however,
prospective offices were required to serve a year in the ranks before entering
officer training school.
And so in October of 1909 he was enlisted into the 33rd Infantry Regiment
stationed at harass.
Four months later,
he won his first promotion to corporal.
It was usual for an aspiring officer to reach the rank of sergeant during the
first year,
but the goal was company commander,
captain to,
I refuse to bestow this rank upon him.
When asked why he had not been promoted to guy commented,
where do you have to be nominated to sergeants,
a boy who would only be at his ease as the grand constable in reflecting upon
this time with a 33rd infantry to go later made the rye remark that the most
valuable lesson he had gotten from his first year in the ranks was that if you
did the exact opposite of what you were told to do by the noncommissioned
officers,
you would get on fairly well.
And to the Military Academy of Saul Sia in autumn of 1910 he quickly and
reputation as an arrogant dandy with an air of superiority.
Two nicknames quickly became attached to him.
No shall Angela gras or Spi Edge.
This last title translates as the great asparagus and wizards.
I'm hardly a reference to his stature.
That's six foot five inches in height.
He towered over virtually everyone that he met.
One of his classmates was the future's general Belvoir commander,
a French troops,
the 1940s battle of Norway.
He remembered the goal as a mediocre students.
He had few friends.
The fact that he graduated 13,000 of his class of 211 in 1912 seems to indicate
that he was somewhat more than mediocre.
It was expected that a young man with the ambition of the goal would be chosen
to join a cavalry regiment is that was traditionally the fastest route to
promotion through the ranks.
How are that?
Charles had already come to the conclusion that the days of the horse soldiers
they were over.
He believes that future wars would be won by the infantry as a resulting made
the decisions you've returned to the 33rd infantry at harass to gold spent the
next two years learning the craft of an army officer.
It didn't take long for that lengthy officer to make an impression,
and the town of her Ross heads turned when he passed by with people being
captivated by both his extraordinary heit and his regal bearing.
Yet his rather caustic,
cold nature repelled more than his impressive appearance attracted not long
after de Gaulle's arrival at harass the 33rd received a new commanding officer,
Colonel Phillip Popol.
Charles develops a great deal of respect for baton.
In his memoirs,
he wrote my first kernel.
Patar taught me the art of command,
but home was also impressed with the goal.
In October of 1913 he recommended his first promotion,
so first lieutenant
when war broke out in August of 1914 the 33rd infantry regimen does part of the
French fifth army was deployed to dinner in order to host the tram in advance
throughout that region to goal was immediately into the action with his first
engagements.
On August the 15th being the battle of denial,
he was wounded in the knee and sent to the hospital to recover.
When he returned to the regimens in October,
many of his men and hello officers,
they were dead.
Two months later,
he was promoted to regimental advertisements.
The 33rd inventory regimen became famous for that ability to crawl out into no
man's lands in order to spy on the enemy.
The intelligence gathered from this work at one to gold,
the quad,
a good metal.
In February,
1915 he was promoted to captain the following month.
Then inconsequential hand wound would become infected.
Leaving him out of action for the next four months.
During the battle of [inaudible] in March of 1916 the goal was winded in the
left thigh by a bear,
nat,
and subsequently captured after passing out from the effects of poison gas.
The goal spent the remainder of the war in a German prisoner of war camp the
attempted to escape five times.
He attempted escape by hiding in a laundry basket,
digging a tunnel of digging a hole through a wall and even posing as a nurse in
order to fool the gods and letters that he wrote to his parents during his
captivity.
He expressed his great frustration that he was unable to participate in the war
at any longer.
He referred to himself as being cuckolded and fell into a state of depression
following the armistice in 1918 he was released and returned to his parents'
home and door doin in the south of France
and only 1920 the goal was posted to Poland,
part of the French military mission deponents that he served as an instructor to
the Polish infantry.
He served with distinction,
I think the rank of major in the Polish army and being awarded the distinguished
two team military parlance,
highest military decoration here.
It sounds of France in 1921 and spent a year as a military history lecturer at
the South Sierra Academy.
He then spent two years studying at the Ecole Minute Tya in Paris.
He graduated with a grade of Sabr or good enough and was then posted to the
Rhineland area of Germany which was under French occupation during the mid 1920s
to go worked as a ghostwriter for his old commander at Eros the now Marshall
Bhutan in 1926 however,
the two had a falling out over a book on the history of the French soldier that
the goal had ghost written called Lasalle da.
In October of that year,
he returned to the brine to commence his military duties that in 1927 after a
dozen years in the army,
the goal was promoted to come on dot.
He was then posted to the occupying forces at Tria in Germany at the heads of
the 19th Shasta Rpa,
which was a light infantry battalion.
Co was a hard task master on his soldiers,
often pushing them beyond what was reasonable.
On one occasion,
he goes into hot water for throwing a soldier into prison for exercising his
right to appeal to as member of parliament for a transfer to a less demanding
units.
Even though he had had a falling out with patrol.
He called in his old commander to help get him out of the mess with the ends of
the allied occupation in the Rhineland in 1929 to goal was posted to Lebanon and
Syria.
He served with distinction with his commanding officer providing him with an
impressive recommendation when he returned to France in 1931 he then received a
posting to the general secretary out of the Supreme War Council based in Paris.
His job description was as a drafting officer for the next six years to gold
gained valuable experience in military bureaucracy.
Over that time,
he worked with government officials in drafting bills ready to do the military.
He worked on a bill for the Organization of France during the event of war,
but it did not pass the Senate throughout this period.
The goal was not shy about voicing his opinion on the military preparations that
France was making and the events of another European war.
He considered the line of fortifications known as the Maginot Line on which
billions of dollars were being spent to be a wasted effort rather than focusing
on a defensive footing.
He contended that the French needed to be proactive through mechanized warfare.
That was fast moving.
In 1934 he wrote a book called toward a professional army,
and it's the outline,
just plans for the future French army with 100,000 men and 3000 tanks in 1937 to
goal came a step closer to realizing this ambition when he was giving commands
of the 507th tank regimens with his promotion of the tank as the key to French
infantry success.
He became a nationally known figure with people calling him Colonel Motors.
Now,
just before we get into his later military career,
I do want to tell you about today's sponsor of war thunder.
They're fantastic because they sponsor longer videos like this and we can really
dive deep into a subject.
So war thunder is a realistic free to play combat game.
And if you're fancy your own kernel motors,
then why not give it a try?
It always amazes me when I hear that there are millions of players on these
online games,
but then again,
I see why it's amazing what games are like these days.
You can look at it right now.
I mean,
it looks incredible and it's free.
So why not?
In this game,
there are over 1,200 historically accurate vehicles.
There are tanks,
aircraft ships,
and just incredible vehicles from the 1930s onwards.
Indeed,
I'm just about to talk about a French tank,
the or 35 and that's totally available in war thunders.
So this game is available on PC ps four Xbox one.
So join us on the battlefield for free using the link below.
Doing that supports this show and it also gets you a free premium.
Tanko [inaudible] and three days of premium time.
As a bonus just for registering
and let's get back to it
with the French Declaration of war upon Germany in September of 1939 the goal
was put in command of the fifth army's five tank battalions,
mostly equipped with our 35 light tanks.
In early 1940 he lobbied for the position of Secretary General of the war
council,
the government's top military advisor,
but he was passed over towards the end of March,
1940 the gold was given command of the newly created Fourth Armored Division
with the German attack on May the 10th the fourth armored.
They went into action on May the 17th they encountered the Germans atom encore
ne.
It was a disaster,
but to goal with 23 of his 90 tanks being destroyed by mine's anti tank weapons
dive bomber and ground attack aircraft.
Two days later,
his reinforced division was decimated for a second time just by being ordered to
withdraw.
He fought on demanding even more reinforcements.
Even through this request was denied.
He managed to push the Germans back to call mark,
but this was only a temporary respite on May the 20th to gold began to referees
in the face of the unstoppable German advance on May the 21st he was promoted to
brigadier general.
On May the 28th the led an attack on a German bridge headed Advil which captured
some 400 prisoners by the beginning of June to gold had been recalled to Paris
where he was offered until you accepted the position of undersecretary of state
for national defense of walk on June the eighth that's where the army commander
in chief wagons who was about to announce the French surrender when to gold,
tried to convince him to fight on vegans.
Laughs despairingly the following day to golf flew to London where he matched
British Prime Minister Winston Churchill for the first time.
His attempts to convince Churchill to put more RF fighters into the battle for
France fell on deaf ears.
Upon his return to Paris,
he wanted to defend the city to the last man,
but Wagan had other ideas.
The government was relocated to tour where a series of meetings with British
officials were held during these meetings.
Gold's fighting resolve in press.
The Brits standing in stark contrast with other French leaders on during the SEC
for the goal was back in London discussing the logistics of a troop withdrawal
to French north Africa.
When he returned to France,
later that day,
you discover the Prime Minister Renzi had resigned to be replaced by Marshall
Patah,
who was intent on signing an artist is with the Germans.
The goal now it fled France for London,
the head of the jam and takeover.
On June the 18th Churchill offered him ads.
I'm on BBC radio to address the French people in the speech,
the golden courage,
this country men to be brave during the occupation,
resisting it as best they could.
The next day he gave another broadcast.
This time he was more critical of the Bhutan government denouncing it as
illegitimate.
On during the 20 seconds following the signing of the armistice to gold took to
the BBC again.
He denounced the surrender and again declared the French government's
illegitimates.
On June the 28th the British government recognized the goal as the leader of
free France has governments in exile,
consisted of three Connell's,
12 captains and three battalions of legionnaires over the following months.
The goals main weapon was BBC radio.
He would give broadcasts and average of three times per month denouncing the
occupation government based in Vishaan's urging Frenchmen to resist the
occupation,
the Bhutan government sentence to gold to death in absentia on the warriors.
The goal was able to slowly build up the free French army.
On April the 21st 1943 he boarded a plane en route to Scotland to inspectors
navy.
The plane almost crashed on take off and it was later found that it had been
sabotaged using acid.
In May of 1943 the gold moved his headquarters to fringe Algiers where he became
the head of the French Committee of national liberation.
He became involved in the planning for the d day invasion.
Although the Americans and British became increasingly frustrated with his
insistence that he was the rightful leader of France.
He was hounded prison on June the fourth of 1944 whereupon trach.
I lost him to address the French people.
They have a BBC radio in anticipation of the allied invasion.
However,
the script he was given did not acknowledge him as the legitimate interim ruler
of France and so he refused to deliver it.
In the wake of the d day invasion of June the sixth 1944 the free French army
under the leadership of general delondra tasks,
gear lenses in southern France and were instrumental in pushing back the
Germans.
On June the 14th the goal returns to France traveling through newly liberated
Norman towns.
He was well received by the townspeople.
He established the capital of the free France and bay,
you and then set off to room where he met the newly installed Italian
government.
From there,
he flew to Washington for his first meeting with President Roosevelt.
The visit was a strange one with Roosevelt not providing the usual privileges of
a visiting head of state.
The gold pushed for the allies to prioritize the liberation of Paris fearing a
communist takeover,
but that was no strategic priority for the allies to focus on Paris.
Still through the goals insistence,
Supreme Allied Commander Dwight Eisenhower agreed that Paris would be
prioritized out of humanitarian and symbolic need.
He also permitted the free French army to be the first to enter the French
capitol on Saturday,
August the 26th the goal ends in Paris in a triumphant march down the shops you
say,
as the procession made its way towards Notradame cathedral,
it came under machine gun fire from Vichy government militia I BBC reporter who
was present noted the goals,
demeanor as a confident,
destroyed forward stating general.
The goal walked straight ahead into what appeared to me to be a hell of fire,
but he went straight ahead without hesitation.
His shoulders flung back and walk right down the center aisle even while the
bullets were pouring about him.
It was the most extraordinary example of courage I have ever seen.
Upon reaching the Great Hall of the Hotel De Ville.
De Gaulle spoke before an ecstatic crowd has inspiring message included these
words.
Paris,
Paris outraged Paris,
broken Paris martyred,
but Paris liberated,
liberated by itself,
liberated by its people with the assistance of the armies of France with a sport
and assistance of the whole of France.
The enemy is faltering,
but he has not yet beaten.
He was still on our soil.
It will not suffice that we,
with the assistance of our deer and admirable allies,
would have chased him from our home in order to be satisfied after what has
happened,
we wanted to enter his territory as is fitting has conquerors.
It is for this revenge,
this vengeance,
and there's justice that we will continue to fight until the last day until the
day of total and complete victory with his bowls and triumphant entry into Paris
to gold won the respect of the world in the days that followed.
The allied leaders made statements recognizing his government is the legitimate
ruler of France.
The provisional government's of the French Republic was established on September
the 10th 1944 to gold then set out on a tour of the country and each city he
freely mixed with the crowds with no regard for his own safety.
Towards the ends of 1944 legal purge was established.
He punished traders during the occupation and remove the last vestiges of the
fishy governments.
Over the course of the purge,
around 2000 people were sentenced to death.
The goal commute it around a thousand of those sentences.
In May,
1945 the Germans surrendered signing an armistice with France in Berlin.
However,
on the very day that victory in Europe was proclaimed,
may the eighth riots broke out in French juniors.
Yeah.
12 days later,
the French artillery fired on demonstrators and Damascus leaving hundreds debt.
This event events caused the advert testy relationship between gold and
Churchill to reach a low add trach or commented that the goal was a great danger
for peace and to Great Britain.
The French constituent assembly unanimously elected to goal is head of the
French government's on November the 13th 1945 after two months of struggles with
communists within his government,
he abruptly resigned and forms the right wing,
a rally of the French people.
He believed that his popularity as a war hero would propel him back to power,
but this gamble,
it didn't pay off.
After three years in the political wilderness,
he left the party and politics behind
the golden retired from public life to write his memoirs.
In 1958 a crisis in Algeria.
It brought him back to politics,
the Algerian National Liberation Front.
It was waging a war for independence and the goal was seen as the kind of strong
national leader who could quash it.
He returned to the presidency and preceded to use brutal force to put down the
rentals.
Both these harsh methods,
they backfired.
The Algerian people were driven father towards independence while around the
welds.
There was condemnation against the French government under intense pressure from
within his own country and abroad to go finally grounds at independence to all
13 French African colonies in 1962 as the cold war develops,
the goal advocated the developments of a French nuclear arsenal.
The country became the world's fourth nuclear power in February of 1963 is later
to go refuse to sign the partial test ban treaty.
In 1965 he was reelected for a second.
70 a tem is French presidents.
He ran his government and just country with a heavy handed dogmatic style that
often drew criticism.
In early 1969 he called for a nationwide referendum on the reform of the Senate
when his proposal was rejected by the people he offered his resignation
following through on a televised promise make two days before the referendum
at the age of 78 having lived an extraordinarily full public life to go retire
to rise and updated version of his memoirs,
he died suddenly on November the ninth 1970 or watching TV.
He complained to his wife that he was feeling pain in his neck and then
collapsed to the ground.
He died within minutes.
The autopsy revealed that he had suffered from a ruptured blood vessel.
The funeral of Charles de Gaulle on November the 12th 1970 it was the largest
and French history.
Today,
he ranks alongside Napoleon as among the greatest of French leaders.
So I really hope you found that video.
Interesting.
If you did,
please do.
Gives a thumbs up below.
Also,
don't forget to check out our sponsor for this episode war thunder.
You'll find them all linked to below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.